jacqueline moreau vous êtes en direct
avec mon frère défense merci d'être là
alors pourquoi annoncer votre
candidature maintenant bonsoir et merci
de me recevoir alors j'avais l'intention
d'attendre le mois de janvier pour
annoncer ma candidature mais ce qui a
fait déborder le vase ce sont les propos
d' emmanuel macron aux médias brut
il ya quelques jours les propos
totalement inacceptables
c'est ça qui a vous a décidé oui tout à
fait parce qu'en fait on n'avait pas un
président en interview dans un média on
avait le candidat emmanuel macron donc
j'estime que le candidat emmanuel macron
a lancé la campagne
donc j à ce moment là j'ai décidé de de
lancer aussi la mienne
qu'est ce qui vous a justement le plus
choqué dans cette interview il vous a
poussé vous à vous déclarer pour la
présidentielle écoutez ou outre l'état
de la france parce que c'est ça qui me
donne la nausée
honnêtement quand on voit ce qu'ils ont
fait de notre pays depuis quarante ans
entre le saccager le dévasté et emmanuel
macron est en train de le ruiner d'une
part pour pouvoir mieux le diluer dans
une robe dont il se rêve en premier
président d'un gouvernement européen
donc ça c'est pas possible
moi je ne peux pas me résoudre à
regarder mon pays mourir de cette façon
sans rien faire alors vous souhaitez
vous gouvernez au plus près des
territoires de vie de chacun comment ils
parvenir
concrètement et bien pour comprendre les
territoires il faut y être dans les
territoires chose que les laits nos
gouvernants actuels et surtout nos
technocrates qui ne sort jamais qu'ils
ne sortent jamais de leur bureau ne font
pas donc ils sont incapables de
comprendre les conséquences des
décisions qu'ils prennent puisqu'il ne
venaient ils ne sortent pas de leur
citadelle donc actuellement par exemple
avec la gestion du coc vide moi
j'aimerais demander à tous ces
technocrates combien ils ont perdu sur
leur salaire parce que aujourd'hui on a
quand même des petits entrepreneurs et
fassent jusqu'au gros entrepreneurs qui
sont en train de tout perdre et à paris
tout le monde s'en fout on nous applique
une politique exclusivement parisienne
qui n'a rien à voir avec les territoires
alors ça serait pas mal que tous ces
gens qui se prennent pour des élus parce
que faut pas oublier que l'été si je
peux me permettre et il ya quand même eu
plus des dents france que dans d'autres
pays et je vous invite à aller aux états
unis pour voir
malheureusement le nombre de personnes
dans la rue qui n'en ont tenu aucun
chômage partiel aucune aide je ne dis
pas que c'est l'idéal en france mais il
ya eu peut-être davantage d'être que
dans certains pays
est ce que vous le concéder alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord mais les aides
qu'on a accordé aux entreprises
il va falloir les rembourser ce sont le
pg e set après que personne ne pourra
rembourser si on ne tombe on nous
empêche de travailler
donc là il va y avoir un très très gros
problème au mois de mai mais juin quand
personne ne va pouvoir rembourser
puisque c'est en comble on nous
maintient en confinement
alors qu'on nous fait appliquer des
protocoles de dengue et on nous
maintient quand même en confinement donc
ça revient à dire qu'ils sont dans les
deux cas incapable d'appliquer d'édicter
des protocoles qui conviennent puisque
il nous confie donc ça veut bien dire
qu'ils confessent leurs propres
compétences
vous annoncez un usage régulier du
référendum c'était l'une des
réquisitions des revendications pardon
des gilet jaune précisant que premier
porteraient sur les questions de
sécurité et d'immigration pour quelles
raisons tout simplement parce que c'est
la première préoccupation des français
actuellement les français ont besoin
d'être protégés et la france a besoin
d'être protégée donc il faut
obligatoirement ça la question ne se
pose même plus si vous voulez on est
rendu à un stade tellement élevé
d'insécurité en france que la question
ne se pose plus
il faut absolument faire un référendum
pour demander aux citoyens français à
tous les citoyens leur avis ce n'est
plus une question qui se décide dans un
bureau à place beauvau à l'elysée ou à
matignon on doit demande elle demandé
l'avis pardon des citoyens français
alors vous avez indiqué avoir pris vos
distances avec la violence du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune tout en restant
fidèle à la non violence du canal
historique quel est votre lien
aujourd'hui avec ce mouvement
alors écoutez j'ai toujours des liens
avec les gilet jaune du 17 novembre
évidemment et aujourd'hui j'ai été
envahie de messages de soutien et de
personnes qui se proposent de m'aider
dans cette candidature parce que
évidemment c'est une candidature une
candidature de rupture avec le système
administratif et une rupture avec les 40
années qu'on déchets que qu'on vient de
subir donc je suis déjà extrêmement
étonné d'avoir autant soutien mais en
tous les cas je les remercie beaucoup
alors les socios c'est une chose il faut
500 parrainages d'élus est ce que vous
êtes optimiste sur ce point tout à fait
je suis optimiste puisque déjà je
travaille avec des maires donc gg dans
l'équipe j'ai des mers et j'ai déjà des
personnes qui se sont proposé d'aller me
meut récolter ces fameuses 500
signatures maison bleue nous ça est
confiant
merci beaucoup jacqueline moreau d'avoir
été avec nous candidate donc à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 merci à vous